13:15 and things are not going too well
for edward ii his nobles despised him
his court favor had just been murdered
he suffered a humiliating defeat at the
hands of the scottish and to make
matters worse due to terrible weather
the harvests had just failed the
population of england at this point had
been growing steadily over the century
since the conquest in agriculture could
only provide enough for subsistence plus
a little bit extra for lords and kings
when the harvest failed it wasn't the
Lords of their retainers who went hungry
it was the peasants the famine which
brought with it a huge rise in civil
disturbance did eventually subside but
Edwards reign did not get any easier his
reign was punctuated with more conflict
with his nobles further failings in
Scotland to put the icing on the cake
his wife Queen Isabella betrayed him she
did this when she went to Paris in 1325
to negotiate peace between England and
France this latest war came as a result
of Gascony being whittled away by the
French king who consistently sided with
French Lords in minor territory disputes
against Edward Edward was unhappy with
this territory slowly being stripped
away and so war which the French won
again Isabella and Edward had a poor
relationship at this point due to wet
wood seizing all of her lands because
she was French whilst in Paris Isabella
met Roger Mortimer who soon afterwards
became her lover Isabella at this point
was clearly plotting against her husband
Edward became increasingly worried of an
impending invasion by Mortimer and
Isabella which he had good reason to
since in 1326 it happened
the invasion wasn't particularly bloody
though and Edward was captured by the
end of the year the next year Edward was
forced to abdicate the first English
monarch to do so on behalf of his son
who was crowned at with the third Edward
the second was imprisoned at Berkeley
castle where he died in mysterious
probably murder related circumstances so
Edward the third early reign was
dominated by Mortimer and Isabella due
to him being 15 and not able to rule on
his own in 1328 the King of France died
without an heir and Edward was the
nearest relative his relation was
through his mother though so the French
considered it invalid which Edward
didn't mind for now by 1330 Edward was
getting pretty sick of Mortimer and
Isabella telling him what to do he had
Mortimer arrested and hanged in the same
year and after that he ruled in his own
name so with Edward now in charge he did
the only thing fitting an English king
invade Scotland Edward did this by
helping Edward Bailey or the son of the
exiled and now quite dead King John
Bailey Oh Bailey War fealty in return
for the English giving
help retaking the throne Edward the
third invaded with the large army in the
Scottish leadership fled to France in
the end Edwards army was unable to
decisively defeat the Scots in their
guerrilla tactics cost the English
dearly just like last time in 1337 the
Scots were able to catch their breath
due to events on the continent Philippe
the six of France the first of the Royal
House of Valois had ascended the throne
in 1328 it was a close ally of the
Scottish Edward the third with the Duke
of Gascony and thus technically
Philippe's battle meaning he wasn't
supposed to disobey his Lord by
conquering his Lord Scottish allies
Philippe decided that Edward was not fit
to be his vassal anymore so ordered the
Gascony before fit Edward said no and
instead made his claim to the throne of
France and in 1340 began to formally
style himself as Edward King of England
and France and Lord of Ireland war would
inevitably follow and this war would
late to be known as the Hundred Years
War
so the merchants Lords and soldiers
which traveled to and from mainland
Europe during this period soon came into
contact with disease in this case the
Black Death and brought it back to
England with them the first outbreak was
in Weymouth followed by Bristol and soon
after London the rest of the South was
infected not long afterwards and by the
end of 1349 all of England bore the
plague in its devastating effects
Scotland seeing the plague as God
punishing the English started to raid
the north pillaging the already
desolated villages this course places
like Durham significant hardship but
importantly it brought the plague back
to Scotland the plague returned many
times over the period the most notable
outbreaks being in 1360 1369 and 1375
overall the death toll of the plague is
debated heavily but general estimates
range from thirty to forty five percent
of the population dying reducing the
country from a population of roughly 4
million to 2.5 million the plague had
major effects on the order of society
since there were no longer enough
peasants to work the landlord's had to
begin negotiating with them and living
standards for surviving peasants began
to rise in the latter half of the 14th
century Edward and his Lords attempted
to regulate wages and try to force the
peasantry to fulfill their duties but
ultimately they failed so Edward the
third died in 1377 and was succeeded by
his grandson Richard the second Richard
was only 10 at the time and so normally
a regent would be appointed in this case
the Regency would have gone to John of
Gaunt
Richard's uncle however John was a very
ambitious man and the other nobles were
worried he would usurp the throne too
instead a Council of advisers was
established to govern in Richards name
so there were two major social problems
that the newly crowned Richard had to do
with the first was the writings of a man
called John Wycliffe who wrote religious
polemics on how the English church was
too rich in that the bishop shouldn't be
allowed to hold positions of power in
government Wycliffe and his followers
also broke sacred rules by translating
the New Testament into English and
criticized the Pope in the clergy
heavily he had powerful back as those
such as John of Gaunt who liked the idea
of the church not having property
because that meant more for the nobles
the movement which Wycliffe had founded
is known as Lalla Dean continued to gain
popularity in the following decades
Richards second issue was that his
Council of Advisors introduced heavy
taxes to fund the war and this upset the
peasantry by 1380 this council was so
hated by everyone that the King
abolished it in 1381 the peasantry began
to resist paying taxes violently in what
is known as the peasants revolt these
peasants led by a man called what Tyler
marched on London where they met the
king who chose to compromise most
notably Richard promise to abolish
surfed in which the peasants didn't
believe because it was a lie so serfdom
was an extremely complicated economic
and social system of mutual rights and
responsibilities between a lord and a
peasant in return for land a home and
access to justice a lords peasant the
serf owed their Lord attacks which was
to be paid with the food they grew with
their labor
there were many types of serfs sometimes
categorizing to free and unfree but be
aware unfree serfs were not slaves
incidentally whilst the negotiations
with the king were ongoing some other
peasants murdered the Archbishop of
Canterbury a couple of days later the
King met Tyler again a scuffle broke out
and Tyler was killed
the revolt spread up and down the
country but by November due to the help
of Henry led the Spencer the Bishop of
Norwich the revolt was crushed the war
in France at this point was not going
well and Richard favoured peace whereas
John of Gaunt favored continuing the war
the two fell out and gaunt left to
pursue his claim to the throne of
Castile the King had appointed two men
into high positions Michel della pol who
was Chancellor and Robert de verre who
was given numerous important regional
positions in 1386 a parliament later
known as the wonderful Parliament was
called and della Paul asked for more
money in taxes Parliament said no and
that furthermore della Paul had to go
the King said no and Parliament
responded by essentially saying that
either he goes or you do in the end
della Paul was removed becoming the
first official ever to have been
impeached by Parliament Richard was not
happy with this and so put de verre in
charge of building a base for royal
support in case of civil war the Lords
who stood in opposition to the king are
known as the Lord's appellant the most
notable were Robert Fitz Allen the Earl
of arendelle and Henry Bolingbroke the
Earl of Derby
Richard under pressure from the
lords conveyed a parliament called the
merciless Parliament which condemned the
Kings closest ally such as to Baron
della pol to death in 1389 John of Gaunt
returned to made up with the king
shortly after this the truce was signed
with France and in 1394 Richard invaded
Ireland increasing the lands under
English control from this to this in the
same year Rich's wife Queen Anne died
without the two having produced an heir
without a son the person who was next in
line to the throne was John of Gaunt
who Richard now saw as an enemy by 1397
Rich's position was looking weak and so
after waiting for many years he struck
against the lords who had humiliated him
this purge often called Richards tyranny
saw Richard men round up and execute the
leading Lords appellant excluding Henry
Bolingbroke Henry had patched things up
with a king but he was soon afterwards
exiled the only real threat to Richard
at this point was tonne of gone gone
died in 1399 though and thus his son
Henry would inherit his lands which
would make him the second most powerful
man in the kingdom henry also
importantly inherited Gaunt's claim to
the throne and richard did not like this
one bit richard chose to seize all of
the exiled henry's inheritance to make
sure that this didn't happen this may
seem like a good idea but arbitrarily
taking your Lords lands and titles away
concern the other lords
if Richard could do it to one Lord he
could do it to any soon after this Henry
returned to England and the other Lords
now very worried about it in ironical
Richard flocked to his side in the end
Richard surrendered and Henry amongst
others put forward his claim to be King
Richard was imprisoned Parliament
declared interposed on Henry Bolingbroke
was crowned King Henry the fourth the
first King of the House of Lancaster the
Plantagenet dynasty was now over and
importantly this greatly weakened the
monarchy as Henry had demonstrated
anyone with a claim to the throne enough
Noble support and a large enough army
could be made King and this had huge
implications for the following century
Richard still being alive cause problems
because some Nobles were still loyal to
him these Lords attempted to assassinate
Henry in what is known as the Epiphany
rising but they failed tried to rebel
failed again but was successful at being
beheaded soon after this Richard died
this is quite likely that Henry the
fourth ordered Richard be allowed to die
of thirst in his cell the Epiphany
rising wouldn't be Henry's last
rebellion in 1400 the glinda uprising
broke out in which a man could away
England or about against English rule
and was proclaimed the Prince of Wales
glyn door pride wales away from
england's grasp for 15 years throughout
his reign Henry had issues with raising
money from his Parliament at first he
was granted
money he wanted but when these vast sums
of revenue didn't turn into the
victories in war that Henry had promised
Parliament accused him of poor
governance Henry did however manage to
root out lollardy by authorizing the
burning of heretics which did enough to
dissuade people from heresy Henry OSA
was the first English King since 1066 to
have his mother tongue be English and
encouraged his Nobles to speak and write
in it his later reign wasn't much better
Henry was plagued by ill health and we
threw from governing the realm and thus
factions developed the main disagreement
was about how to pursue the war with
France which was itself undergoing a
civil war Thomas arendelle the
Archbishop of Canterbury led one of
these factions and was dominant between
1408 and 1411 Henry's health
deteriorated and he died in 1413 and his
son succeeded him as henry v one of the
most notable warrior kings in english
history I hope you enjoyed this episode
and thank you for watching there are
some books in the description if you'd
like to learn more
you